the animals from the golf channel Notah
Begay the third back here in the Rich
Eisen show how are you noted so I'm
doing great rains just arrived here at
Bertel just in time to start the
festivities this week well so how I
guess get let's start with the weather
I'm not going to ask you for traffic so
it's just only it's only weather on the
fours right now Notah what do you got
for well that's good cuz they drive on
the other side of the road that would be
nice much much help in that regard
so is it supposed to be nice I guess for
the actual championship
well they had exceptional weather all
week until today had a little bit of
late rain and tomorrow is supposed to be
intermittent and then definitely there's
going to be some weather expected I
think right around 80% chance on Friday
so one of the things that people will be
talking about is which side of the draw
certain players end up on and we know
that if you end up on the wrong side of
the draw
especially in this particular event with
how the weather can change and play such
a drastic impact on performance certain
players will be knocked out so who are
the favorites based on the set up and
how Royal Birkdale plays who do you got
for me here well your favorites the
obviously world number one Dustin
Johnson although he's come off two cuts
to miss cuts and hasn't played a weekend
round since May probably still coming in
as the betting favored but based on
performance you probably have to look at
three players John ROM being probably
the youngest in newest face that's
making a splash on the PGA Tour and then
jordan Spieth and Rickie Fowler who have
played the best golf this year both of
them have two seven top-10 finishes this
year and they're number one and number
two in scoring hours on the PGA Tour so
they're putting up some pretty
spectacular numbers and with the way the
golf course is set up there's going to
be a lot of crossing winds small targets
very penal course as they call it we
call it thick heavy ralph back in the US
but there's going to be a premium on
ball striking okay so give me give me
somebody that's not on the radar screen
of a lot of people that you think has a
chance to take
--home the Claret Jug you know look at
maybe options 1a you you might look at
hideki Matsuyama serger garcia obviously
is a consistent performer in the open he
has 10 top-10 finishes so i mean just
kind of a really suits his game he's a
wonderful ball striker there's not as
much of a premium on putting not to say
that it's not important but greens are
tad bit slower a little bit flatter than
what we're used to seeing in some of the
other major championships so for those
that are sergio fans after his last
major win this past April and Augusta he
certainly is going to fact I believe
where's Rory McIlroy in the grand scheme
of things do you think in the golf world
right now no tom Rory's probably one of
the if not the biggest raw talent that
we have in the game just says calendar
some some tough rot rocky waters the
last couple months coming off an injury
early in the year the South African Open
tried to come back from that didn't
really see too many results had through
the Masters had three top-10 finishes so
maybe was starting to see some things
turn in the right direction but then
since the Masters um had to withdraw
from some event and hasn't seen top-10
so he's coming off to miss cuts one at
the US Open and one at his event in
Ireland so not a lot of momentum for
Rory but I certainly wouldn't cross him
off your list of contenders and Spieth
he's never played Royal Birkdale he's
been there said Saturday working on his
game what do you make of that well I
like Jordan for a couple reasons number
one his his weak the weakest Clubman is
back this year just statistically
speaking is this driver he ranks outside
the top 150 in strokes gained off the
tee but once you get inside say 225
yards there's really nobody better his
putting a solid it's certainly not what
we saw in 2015 but it's certainly good
enough for him to be a factor and he's
coming off three week layoff he played
six consecutive weeks the last of those
weeks he chalked up a win at the
Travelers Championship chipping in in
the first
[ __ ] to beat Daniel Berger so only
four players are coming in here off off
a win in their last event that's jordan
Spieth John Ron Bryson D Shambo and
Cabrera Bale so those four guys have a
little bit of confident that I would say
would be a little bit more than the
others Notah Begay the third from the
Golf Channel joining me here so much it
gets made of US Open courses no to when
they some when it's not playing
traditional open US Open courses right I
mean the last couple of chambers Bay and
obviously what we just saw a couple of
weeks ago where it looks like an Open
Championship set up what would would the
folks at the Royal and Ancient ever do
the same I know that there's a rotation
here but what they ever maybe just throw
the Open Championship in a US Open style
course well I I think they did they did
once and it was in 1999 at Carnoustie
and they they got blasted for it it was
they brought the fairways and Curtis
these are typically a really hard
driving golf course anyway and it just
didn't suit the way the open is supposed
to play and I think that the USGA and
the US Open has to a certain degree lost
its identity it used to be one of the
toughest tests in golf but in an effort
to I don't know whether it was increase
ratings garner more attention from fans
or whatnot become more popular with
players the setup changed about eight to
ten years ago and you're starting to see
courses that don't have as much Ralph
have graduated ruffs and then what we
saw at Erin Hills which was big driving
areas and when you add a little bit of
water.that it just kind of becomes a
bombers fest and certainly don't take
anything away from bush Kefka but he
took advantage of it and you played a
course at put out in front of you and
congrats to him for being able to do
that yeah why what why why did it what
is the US what just why can't the USGA
be like the RNA here right I mean looks
um I think a little bit has to do with
just people like drivable par fours
that's become kind of really a a trendy
thing right now because we talked about
it we
Notah we talked about it with the
Kurdish strange like III miss Corey
Pavin hidden you know the fairway wood
off the deck at Shinnecock those you
know where guy was like five seven
soaking-wet having a chance to win the
US Open well you know I absolutely read
tonight I just I just think it's a
transition period I mean the I think all
of the governing bodies are trying to
find a way to grow the game and trying
to fight it find a way to reach into a
different section of the population a
younger section of our population to
increase participation and making things
fun more popular a little bit more
trendy might seem to be a good idea but
it certainly has gone against what you
would classify as a typical US Open set
up historically speaking I mean the
opens that I played in probably the
toughest test and except for one player
Tiger Woods everybody else struggled at
Pebble Beach in 2000 and I mean it was
just simply one of the hardest golf
courses I've ever played the rough was
knee-high and the greens were hard and
they were small and he really proved in
one of the greatest performances that
we've ever seen that you can still play
that kind of kind of venue Ernie elf in
his second at three over and Tiger Woods
won at 12-under and it was simply one of
the most incredible things I've ever
seen and I don't think the players mind
doing that once a year and knowing that
they're going to be required to hit
fairways in order to hold greens and get
it close to hole locations and it
certainly hasn't been that way for a few
years now a couple more minutes left
with Notah Begay calling in from Royal
Birkdale where again NBC Sports is a
hundred and forty hours of television
coverage the to this 146 open right here
on the Rich Eisen show how is Tiger note
up as you can tell Tigers doing well I'm
real happy that he sought out
professional help and as you know one of
his close friends for the over the last
20 years certainly never want to see
someone that you care about go through
something like that its challenges that
many people face in this country in
dealing with you know medications and
whatnot and I'll just extremely happy
that he committed to a program when
they're completed it and now it's sort
of the next 30 to 60 days is really
important as well to get to support and
the follow-up and sort of reconstruct
different habits and to do new things
that are productive in your life so how
far is golf away from him
do you think well before the the
incident Golf was I think 15 months 18
months out so I don't think that
calendar has changed there might be some
tweaks with regard to I think he's going
to have some choices he's going to have
some choices as far as what whether he
wants to pursue golf again or where his
body's at and probably starts thinking
about that in a few months okay and one
last one for you here I know you don't
speak for him but I know you're tight
with him dota do you think because you
mentioned about the problem that so many
people in this country faced with
medication and opioids etc do you think
that Tiger once once this all settles
down for him hopefully in a positive
manner would become a face for this sort
of thing that and and geto you know
there on on behalf of those who suffer
from this to eradicate my you know I can
only speak from from my own experience
in having dealt with addiction myself
and you know that's one of the steps I
mean when things get to a certain point
and you feel like your commitment to a
new lifestyle has benefited your life
and they encourage you to advocate to
others that are facing similar problems
and the biggest thing about those
circles is to demonstrate to others that
they're not alone in dealing with these
challenges and I think that's one of the
things that's been clearly evident to me
and being out here at the open being at
PGA Tour events on a regular basis is
there's so many players you know had
already else come up to me and just say
hey man pass along my best to Tiger
we're pulling for him just let him know
that he's not alone in this and he's not
having to deal with these things without
the support of of the world of golf and
I just think that goes a long way in
dealing with something like this well
same from us you're on the show if you
don't mind you know
certainly on a date this would have been
stuart scott's birthday by the way
everybody should go get ice cream for
that i just remember he and i just
talking about him all the time meeting
him several times and i just know
everybody who who has come across him
and feels the same way notif so please
send our best absolutely sure well rich
and yeah I do miss Stuart myself he was
great for me supported our foundations
work and certainly tough when you lose
someone that's such a benefit to their
community and their network and
certainly still miss Stuart
yeah and now today again is his
daughter's day and said as they're known
on Twitter want everybody to go take
their kids for ice cream today because
it's it's stuart scott's birthday and
it's National Ice Cream day the way they
like to put it and so have one over
there across the pond on behalf of
Stuart a nice to ask me twice when it
comes to ice cream I'm in could notice
thanks for the call appreciate it you
got it you know that's
Notah Begay the third act Notah Begay 3
on Twitter so Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country
and audience if you like that video be
sure to download our apps don't have any
memory on your phone let's start to
delete some of those slow-mo videos you
have and you know which ones I'm talking
about